alrigh alright hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica let me do that again just in
case it was a little too early hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to subnautica how are you
all doing this wonderful wonderful
morning in the wonderful wonderful
depths of the ocean that we currently
are in right now how you guys doing yes
welcome welcome welcome this is going to
be the final episode of subnautica but i
got a lot of things to do before I get
to the final episode of subnautica but
or more specifically before we finally
leave this godforsaken planet once and
for all and we never have to see the
depths of the ocean ever again which
would be wonderful if it only it could
be true then maybe it's true I don't
know hey welcome welcome welcome
yes alright so where we stand right now
in the terms of subnautica is we
currently have everything that we need
to be able to get the gear going get the
hatching enzymes I actually need to make
those right now I'm pretty sure I can
make them in my base right here right
now but everything that we need to do
that is right here we've got the rotten
bulb bush sample I hope it doesn't need
to be fresh but if it does I can get one
on the way
over to the place that I need to go and
we've got the iStock seed the sea crown
see the ghost weed seed and the fungal
sample now this should be everything
that we need to be able to make the
hatching enzymes and if it's not well
then I'm just boned eternally and
forever I am always 100% bone but it's
not bone right there
so we finally have the hatching enzymes
we've actually done that before but that
doesn't mean that it actually took place
because that was before the official
release of the game hello hi yes so
here's how it's gonna go I'm gonna go
down to this see Emperors container and
I'm gonna go get these hatching enzymes
underway I'm gonna be cured and
there's a number of things that I need
to complete before I actually get to the
end of the game number one among them is
there is apparently a cute and adorable
little creature companion that I need to
get that's located in one of the de
Ghazi bases I believe it's in the one
that is in the depths of near where mr.
Pfister is right now and if I go down
there I'm pretty sure I'll be able to
find it but if not oh well but I'm gonna
explore that after I get this done now
in order to do this I think I'm actually
going to just take bubble butt over
there and I should be able to dodge you
I don't know if the depths are good yeah
it'll probably fall it'll probably be
fine
ooh you look a little damaged there let
me just fix you up a squeeze or two
can I get in not working all right
whatever I'll do it later all right
so delightful so we're gonna go and
we're gonna cure ourselves and
effectively we're gonna cure the
entirety of the ocean here every single
thing that is infected in fact I would
love to be able to see if those things
can be infected as well like those
things just covered in an enormous like
coating of green pustules actually I
don't know I want to see that but I just
wonder if that's even possible I haven't
seen if there's like a a Reaper
Leviathan that could be infected with
the disease as well just a bunch of
stuff that I don't want to I don't I
have to endure so I'm gonna take dashing
enzymes what is that what did I just see
down there oh it's probably another vent
okay all right yeah so I'm gonna oh yea
it's another vent okay so I'm gonna be
going through here I'm gonna be doing
this in stages I'm gonna be going
completing an objective and then I will
come to the base take a little bit of
breather because today is gonna probably
be a long day it's gonna take me at
least a few hours to be able to get
through everything that I want to get
through but that's okay because that
means that we can get everything done in
a relaxing atmosphere we don't have to
worry about being dead - horrible
monstrosity --zz that exists in the
oceans here and we can just go our
way-hey let's see where am i my ops
reject tree wait hang on exactly
okay that's there where's the where's
the goddamn Island yeah I was pretty
sure oh yeah I think it's over there all
right let me repair before I actually
get into the depths of horror here hey
bubble gum we're gonna be fine everybody
everybody just hold on all right
hey okay hold on to your butts hold on
to your butts it's about to get bad my
video is oh oh oh hang on huh
all right everybody hold on to your
butts everybody hold on to your butts
I got a oh that's not good all right
hold on
there's a little bit of a technical
difficulty everybody hold on your butts
now shut up Karen I got stuff to do
all right let me just hang on everybody
hold on hold on to your buds back I hope
this doesn't break it cuz god damn I'll
I'll be breaking hang on one second here
okay did that help if it did it's great
if it didn't well
then huh I'm eternally boned all right
let's see what happens hello everybody
if you're watching this now that means
that I fixed it if you're not and
everybody needs to clench their butt
cheeks as hard as they can
okay hello can you see me can you hear
me it's a boy have I here am I here am i
anywhere help please somebody help me
it's all good kinda I can see better
okay yeah you like trains okay all right
all right then it's good good bad good
bad strong bad strong sad good bad okay
all right it's all good it's good okay
we're back up and we're ready to go now
that probably broke the archive for
everybody watching in the future but
that just means that you lucky people
watching in the current don't have to
experience any of that I'm alive okay so
hopefully that'll be a little bit better
I'm getting good reports across the
board everything seems to be good
and wonderful and everyone's happy it
was getting everything they want life
all right so we're almost where we need
to be now there's every possible there
you are okay you stay over there hmm
all right there's every possibility the
one I actually take bla bla through the
the container like this that it's not
gonna survive when it's in the actual
container down there oh thank you -
thank you - violet Marshall wow that's
that's totally unnecessary thank you so
much
I will also I will be taking a break
once I like I said earlier I was gonna
take breaks at every every few moments
to be able to read chat and stuff and
thank everybody so much for being here
so I'm gonna take that in stages I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna accomplish things
and then I'm gonna come back and I'm
gonna do that all right let's see if
bubble buff blows up if if bubble bop
blows up then that's that's that is what
it is but thank you - violet Marvel not
Marshall violet Marvel thank you so much
for that just said hello Marc thank you
to everybody that has been contributing
through super chat you don't need to do
that you don't need to do that please
please you don't need to do that I
appreciate it but let's keep it keep it
for yourselves like you can buy yourself
something special sorry
I just pissed myself but sorry about
that peeper I just wanted to get over
here and have a good time but anyway
bubble buds not blowing up yet so that's
nice
hey paper come here come here paper why
are you running away from me paper are
you running away all right hello Bubba
all right so I got what I need and I
should just be able to slam this bad boy
in here and all is good in this universe
this is sad we have to experience this
good I'm so sad
whoo jiggly jiggly hello welcome to the
world
whoa ah look at you guys
oh you're right out there all right
hello oh the little bamboo this is just
little bamboos oh oh they're so squiggly
they actually have animations now so
cute oh oh look there are they nuzzling
up against mama
[Music]
Oh
no emergency starvation imminent secret
calorie intake and vgp uh-huh that don't
matter right now Karen that don't matter
someone's suffering more all right maybe
I'll just join one of these peepers out
from under oh I'm sure she won't mind
right now going all right for the
greater good yond Big E Big Poppa Pump
I thought something would be happening
by now but I guess I just got a stare
and sadness eventually it will I have no
air can I can I run back to bubblegum
real quick and get some air please oh
shut up Karen is this whoa who is that
the poop that I can rub all over me hand
wait oh that's the good stuff
oh yeah that's some nice well that's not
good well that sucked in through my
gloves a little concerning but all right
am I am i cured have I been have I been
cured I'm cured I'm cured complete vital
signs normal
no remaining yes yes yes all right Big E
Big E you okay oh that's some hefty
bruise your big paw you're bigger than
Bo ho hey okay you're bigger than big
you're bigger than I thought big was all
right okay well good skin biggie you got
to talk to me
Big E hello how's your tentacles doing
they're good healthy oh this is sad
she's not talking to me she's not
talking to me it's gonna be big come on
buck up chin up there come on
big big big em big papa amps mama amps
sorry
big momma amps don't all right well
maybe she'll talk to me when I leave now
that our babies are here aren't her
babies supposed to like go out the door
oh wait are they already out the door
have they already left
but when did they leave well that's
weird huh
oh it's so strange oh well I guess
there's nothing else to do besides just
head out hmm
hey all right
well guess we're all done
hmm
she's supposed to say some dummy she's
posted say some
that's a chick she spoke to talk to me I
know net product as I bugged the game
because it's like such an old saved oh
but we heard her talking before god hey
but now she's not dead Hey look on the
bright side she's not dead
that's good she's just tired from
birthing those sweet babu's she's tired
what a sweet sweet sweet lady oh that's
wonderful
oh oh there's the babies watch out
there's a Reaper Leviathan around here
and you don't want to be around when you
know oh you puked it out oh you puked it
out okay Oh gross can you stop puking
I don't think babies like this are
supposed to puke this much I mean I know
this is like a steady stream of cured Oh
everywhere you do up there it goes again
all right well okay little guy all right
let's all seem healthy I'm just gonna
say it right now that's not healthy Oh
gonna you're gonna puke again you're
gonna puke come on you can do it come on
big guy what did I hit did I hit by him
sorry
oh I hit a rock not them okay we're all
good it's clobbered I thought I just
clobbered one of the babies oops oops
they're already they already puked it up
so I guess they're fine
oh man but they really want to puke
these bad boys up but that one's little
companion there okay all right well it's
night now I've got other stuff to do
your mom's alive that's great everyone's
happy and everything's good to go so we
don't need to worry about anything else
right
right yeah yeah we don't need to worry
about anything else okay what we're
cured everybody's fine biggie stole Oh
good in this neighborhood let's try not
to get mortared by the reaper Leviathan
that I can hear over here let let's take
a wide berth around this we ain't gonna
Karen you're so worried about everything
you know what are you just gonna relax
in life why can't I just stay on the
frickin surface there we are
ah space I'm gonna be near you real soon
you don't worry about a thing you fast
moving planted over there actually I'm
pretty sure this planet is orbiting that
planet I'm not 100% sure about that I
don't know the lure of subnautica too
much but I'm pretty sure this planet is
actually just orbiting that one and I
think actually that planet has another
orbiting body at some point here I'm not
sure but it is what it is so turn the
turn the gun off that's important
[Laughter]
sure I'll wait you guys sure you sure
about that you know I'm gonna I don't
think you guys right um I'm gonna make
an overriding call here I don't think we
need to turn off the gun because if I
know something about my piloting skills
it's the it's pretty good and so I think
I can avoid pretty much anything I'm so
worried boo hoo a gun might shoot us
down you worry too much about everything
you just need to relax and calm down and
collectively just put your tits down a
bit and everything will be okay
you guys are worried not your biggest
concern not my biggest concern that's
absolutely sure about that
I don't know what wouldn't you do ow
[Laughter]
oops there we go
things are go smoothly smoothly real
smoothly yeah oh yeah what do you think
of my new glasses I got I got these just
the other day I like them they're
different than any other glasses that
I've ever had their number one rimless
and number two circular so that's
awfully nice okay
so like I was saying I'm gonna like go
through a little bit and thank everybody
so much for who's been contributing to
this let me just hang on one second
all right there we go all right thank
you to dark mega gaming hey Mark can you
change the name of your rocket how about
this name hate the ocean thank you very
much Black Butler AJ hey Mark I was
cleaning the house the other day and it
sounded just like the animation noise
for time or also if you could say hi to
Xander for me it would mean the world to
me well thank you very much thank you
two wheel lock warlock they need to Bob
aka lapis Garrett Griffin Sean Lyons
thank you so much said I admire you so
much mark I don't know what yeah Garrett
Griffin said don't forget to turn off
the big [ __ ] gun but uh are you
talking about yeah Kashmir 77 new series
play minecraft with friends without
cheats and build cities - alcohol of
course I think minecraft that whole
thing with my buddies Bob and Wade
that's just you know we're gonna let
that lie drunk minecraft was a fun time
but you know we can only do so much with
it and given that I can't drink alcohol
anymore I'd like to let that series be
what it was in the past which was great
at the time thank you - redrawn the SS
for M 1991 thank you - oh man fresh KJ
Brian toodle dc3 II Noah Baker Jereme
Newton Holden Dotson moving violation
Pinkie Pie rolls
kairos Paw Paw goes Devin Hart Jeff
Eider mr. lover I wish I could read all
these chats but I can't thank you to
span thank you for being such an amazing
person mark your videos are and a
wonderful personality I don't know about
that have helped me with my depression
and my difficulty through vet nor
veterinary school
don't ever stop being them
please play white day a labyrinth named
school well thank you very much span and
span I'm gonna put your name on a locker
right here very much thank you so much
all right and thank you mister mean
Black Butler thank you to Ryan bolado
hey mark I was curious if you could say
hi to my friend Julia Brock then for me
I'd really a brother
I'm family very much so eat okay there
we go got that okay all right all good
here all right and then thank you -
violet Marvel as I said before thank you
very much thank violet Merville thank
you very much okay all right so that's
enough for exactly that also thank you
to everybody that is subscribed and
super chatted so far I don't have enough
time to read absolutely everybody's and
to be perfectly honest you doc don't it
don't worry about that stuff don't worry
I am super slow I haven't been drinking
up and enough piss hey Lily get my oh
I'm surfing I seem to have a problem I
am NOT a good survivalist I get rid of
the Cure and instantly I just somehow
manage to screw myself over eternally I
don't want to get some food here Gary
Gary Gary Gary Gary paper come here wear
that Gary go paper paper paper I've been
for bubble have one big big purple for
pop where'd you go pretty bad you're not
edible right come on alright someone
cooked it actually get some food in me
so Karen can stop screaming at me how
stupid I am you tell me how stupid I am
I know exactly as much as bad as that I
am all right so now that we got that
paper Gary I don't know if the Reaper
will take a Gary mmm
something tells me that the Reaper don't
want nothing about no Gary here yeah all
right yeah that should be enough food
gloms long long Rob oh yeah wash that
down to piss I'm good to go
ah so
next thing that I need to do now that
everything's cured Biggie's still alive
oh yeah all right Piggy's still alive we
got stuff to do so we're gonna go down
we're gonna get mr. Pfister and we're
gonna find this egg for this special
little creature that's gonna be joining
us on the rest of our adventure and I'm
gonna figure out a way to get them on
the rocket to be able to blast them up
to spice and I'm pretty sure and correct
me if I'm wrong but I'm pretty sure the
little creature is down in the diggity
base down in the grand reef and if she's
not
well then I'm boned anyway all right
Adolphe paper can I have one of you just
in case I think I'm gonna need it for a
rebirth like swing by because I'm gonna
be going down here just by my lonesome
because I just want to grab mr. Pfister
on the way down what are you talking
about
turn it off the gun I don't know what
you mean what are you talking about
oh just crew crew and Chuck donated $200
through the super chat mark I had a
friend pass away a little while ago and
your videos always helped me feel better
so thanks well thank you very much I'm
really sorry about your friend passing
away I I wish I could do something more
to thank you and thank you for being so
generous that is as ridiculous but
seriously thank you so much you are
awesome and everybody here that is
contributing to that you're absolutely
awesome but you don't need to honestly
you don't need to please don't but no
please buy yourself something nice it's
it's too much all right so I'm gonna get
over here I'm a gear grab mr. Fisher and
we're gonna be on our way somebody touch
my mouse bar god I don't know what that
means
all right put on my gloves again I guess
that's somewhat important if you have to
say so
I hate the noises down here absolutely
hands turn the cannon off oh you guys
are so worried about this cannon I don't
even think a cannon exists in this game
I don't even know what you're talking
about I think you guys are worried about
nothing
the cannon is just a rumor it's just
it's it's not real the cannon is like an
analogy for something and you guys are
so worried about this cannon it doesn't
exist
all right I don't know what you guys are
even talking about so oh yeah oh I'm
glad to believe there's some giant gun
some enormous gun that's going to shoot
down my rocket oh yeah right that seems
absolutely ridiculous I have no idea no
idea what you're even talking about I
think you guys should take your silly
ideas and shove them straight up your
ass so if I could be so bold as to say
that you will get shot down by what your
imagination Oh your imagination is gonna
shoot me down in the middle oh yeah oh
yeah sure okay yeah like I would go
through all the trouble of actually
surviving all this time building the
rocket just to get shot down at the end
are you crazy or am I crazy here if it
gets you all right everybody take your
take your wild running imaginations and
just get out cut it out get out of here
guys you guys are so so crazy everybody
come on you guys are on my side let's
divide the audience here I'm gonna
create a pole no I'm gonna create a pole
right now I'm gonna create a pole all
right all this time shut up shut up me
I'm gonna create a pole all right is
there a quote cannon I think not
cannon with two ends not cannon sure the
one answer is sure yeah let's say yes
and and the other answer is of course
not stupid all right so I created a card
where there's a nice pole there if you
guys if you guys want to simply do
okay all right so if you haven't seen
that you can go to the cards I just
created it but I'm pretty sure we all
know she I'm pretty sure we all know
exactly what's going on there with this
quote-unquote
cannon oh look it's my other face I
haven't seen you in ages
wait have I seen you in ages did I come
back here oh yeah I came back here to
get get a big box Barry ah
mr. Pfister how you doing what is what's
in you mr. Pfister nothing absolutely
dick diddly just the way I wanted to hi
Steve okay whatever I've got so much
boost I've forgotten which rad ow my
head my noggin oh there we go
thank you thank you very much for that
all right I forgetting one module do you
actually know god I hate you I hate you
Steve mr. Pfister you're such an [ __ ]
okay what am i hitting my head on all
right okay all right okay yeah sure
okay yeah and why can't I I can't I
can't access those well all right didn't
it do anyway it's all good let me get a
cup of coffee let's see you'll be the
Quarian said you'll be fine the
cuttlefish will keep you safe from the
cannon with its cuteness one does not
simply kill cuteness all right I know
all these crazy sacks of [ __ ] think that
they're they don't know mmm coffee
Americana some sweet delicious car
there hey let's get some Oh forgot about
this game is very old and very buggy I
don't know if I've mentioned that but
it's all good
it's all right okay so we don't need to
be here anymore oh wait a minute now we
don't need that I don't think we need it
at all let me just see if there's any
sort of materials here I don't think
there is I'm pretty sure I came down
here and I cleared this place out
already salt salt some gold depleted
nuclear rods don't need that what is in
here man I'm pretty sure it's just salt
this is the saltiest base in the entire
entire ocean air all right I'm pretty
sure that's it okay so I'm gonna go down
to the de gauzy base I'm gonna get
everything that I need everything that I
need oh whoa hang on a second things are
gonna pop up here Thank You monkey
Rodriguez hey Mark I wanted to thank you
for everything you do I've been watching
your video since the beginning and I
love all of it I've been suicidal for
some time now in your videos and vlogs
help me get through the days I wish I
could get more thank you again
well thank you monkey Thank You monkey
for being here and I'm really sorry
about that you're feeling down like that
and I'm glad that my videos could help
in whatever way they do but in all
honesty it's it's you that's keeping you
here and I really appreciate that you're
strong enough to be able to do that and
I'm just glad that I'm here with you so
thank you so much for being here with us
and you don't need to do you don't need
to contribute at all you don't need to
contribute thank you so much but it's
not necessary really it's not I really
appreciate it though so thank you guys
all right I know there's an entrance to
this assuming hey hey hey you can't
bother me anymore
I'm cured hey I'm gonna punch you in
your face hey hey hey hey I'm cured I'm
cured man don't you dare don't no no
[Laughter]
all right you didn't need to worry about
me anymore what's in this groove boss I
love a good crevasse oh I can bear laws
too tight it's 200 help help help I'm
stuck it's 127 hours in here oh there we
go
oh my god I love a good crevasse but not
when my ass my pro digis ass is stuck
within it that's not as much as I would
like
turn off the gun what are you talking
about wait yeah let me check my Paul
here let's see what the results of my
poll are let's hope this doesn't blast
noise at me again all right here we go
wait okay poll here what's the poll
results of course it's a whopping 53%
that say there doesn't exist a cannon
you're off your gourd if you think
there's a cannon
you're obviously in the minority here so
why don't you get your brain checked
about whether or not there's a cannon
stop listening to all the fake news out
there about these cannons that are
threatening our existence it's so
incredibly silly right now you guys
don't understand how silly you sound
whoo I love a good crevice I'm gonna get
stuck in that aren't I yeah I love a
crevice I don't know there weren't all
these crevices before oh hey I made it
wait this goes nowhere ah that's not as
good a crevasse as I was hoping it was
gonna be
hang on wait Oh getting jiggly with it
oh well that's a noise all right where's
the goddamn entrance into this stupid
thing
I know I know who's near that wrecked
ship but I have no idea where okay um
[Music]
it's gotta be somewhere everybody hold
on to your butt's I have no idea what's
going on in it and I don't know where I
am I don't know where I'm going on I
don't know where I am
we're am bi where am I go B this doesn't
seem right
something's not right about what nice
but okay here Oh where's where's it go
there there there there there that's got
to be it right that's got to be it
something like that
whoa hey whoa way to make an entrance
there douche nozzle
are you just you with your don't word
see I'm cured
I this is uncomfortable that's right get
out of here that's right get out here
you think I bet that warper believes
that there's a gun out there Yeah right
okay all right whoa I have that I have
this bag I have this poop got some poop
ray around the poop why do I have this
poop why do I want this poop so badly is
the question that I have in my mind hey
that's that's poop off yep nutrient-rich
manure suitable for bioenergy I just
picked up a bunch of poop all right okay
all right sure sure sure
where's the goddamn entrance to this
stupid thing I feel like an idiot
am I an idiot guys wait do I need to
create another poll am I in a kid here
or have I just forgotten where whoa it's
a herd of them that is a lot of weight
that's a lot of them
why are you guys on it's good it's good
what's uh what's going on hey you guys
doing um can I help you wait oh yeah
wait whoa whoa whoa
Clint tfh mark your videos are fun to
watch especially subnautica
I just have one request that some of
this money goes to helping people like
myself who have depression absolutely
absolutely
it absolutely will like I will
definitely do that because my god that's
ridiculous thank you so much I will I
will absolutely contribute that straight
over because my goodness you guys are so
generous you don't need to be just I'm
just streaming subnautica for fun but
thank you guys seriously
oh here's the entrance gosh darn it I'm
such an idiot
I'm such an idiot well thank you so much
for that and thank you everybody that
has been contributing through super chat
it's really unnecessary I will probably
probably right after this I'll make a
donation too and we will do a charity
event at some point for people that have
depression and stuff we've done things
for like the DBS a before and it's
something that's very important to me so
I want to make sure that I give back
wherever I can so thank you everybody
that's been doing this but I wanna I
wanna read it this isn't a charity
stream this is just a stream for funsies
so thank you guys that have been joining
us so far now again turn off the gun you
guys are so worried about this I
pathetical gun it's not a problem see if
there was a gun I would be shot down by
now and I'm obviously now I'm gonna kill
this crab squid and what kill this
frickin crab squid oh he's gonna get it
well you're about to get it locked on
target
gotcha gotcha get ready for the Thunder
oh we seem to be paralyzed but I'm not
letting go
yes come here you where are you
command-u oh yeah you want some of this
one some of this oh you you don't want
you don't want none of this oh god your
face oh oh what are you doing where you
going where you going where you go where
you go that's right are you dead you
dead you're not dead yet are you going
to be though are you gonna be oh oh
what's that oh oh no oh no oh no
shouldn't a mess with me huh shouldn't a
mess with me shouldn't miss me shouldn't
have been around this big ah see babe
well that was the noise alrighty then
okay okay alright
okay so now that we know we've got that
taken care of that menace to society now
we need to go in here and I believe I'm
not a hundred percent sure but I believe
the thing that I require there we go
I believe what I require is in here and
I'm not sure where do you guys know
where the creature egg for the cute
little cuttlefish do you know where that
would be is it even in here am I in the
right spots in PDA I've already gotten
these PDAs in the past so I don't
imagine they're gonna provide any new
information for me I would have thought
that it would have been in here I would
have thought yeah anyway let's keep
looking around oh my god oh my god you
are well in permanence days oh my god
oh you'll be right next to the poop Oh
oh my god
Hey look it's an orange tablet pick us
out well alright then I don't need that
anymore but I love this game is I love
just bugging out the games log log what
is that what is that what is that okay
whatever I don't know where the log went
here we go just as tentacles keeper then
to reach Shanna seed light in one hand
the jagged piece of scrap metal and the
other she meant a butcher that beast or
die tryin
the last I saw her she has a metal
lodged in its neck as the monster did
its best to shake her contorting off
into the darkness I'm certain she got
her wish then I thought I saw a light
deep below me I hope maybe part of Swamp
clear I followed it
no I wonder whether I saw anything at
all our oxygen is low the habitat is
gone I can't see the sky something
surely has the scent of my blood how
[ __ ] bad-ass is made up oh my god I
don't think you guys understand Maeda
literally with a see glide and a piece
of not even a knife not even a normal
knife a see glide and a piece of metal
lodged under a huge crack in which I'm
sure was the sea Emperor or a Reaper
Leviathan and stabbed it in the neck
just with the sea glide and a piece of
metal I wish I was a third that badass
maida over that is the most incredibly
hardcore thing I've ever heard of in my
entire life I wish I wish I was that
cool oh man and it's sad cuz I know I
never will be
I'll never be that cool my god that is
redonkulous is that actually a way out
of this oh there were sealing
compartments oh ah [ __ ]
no I'm out I'm out of jump okay we're
good we're good
scusi bouche we're out we out II whoo
[Applause]
man if I'd have known that I would have
gone down what is this all right
whatever don't matter what it is oh that
was oh that's super convenient huh well
wish I would have known about that I
think my base is like right over here
somewhere
oh well not important but yeah that is
like I am NOT that cool I am NOT that
cool I did check one of the previous
episodes that I've been playing to this
I scream like a little baby every single
time I even remotely hear a reaper
Leviathan let alone see one whoa oh hell
yeah
give me that course I'll drill that
quartz baby
Oh drill baby drill and I think yes it
goes right into my eight off that is
good stuff oh that's good this takes a
while to drill though and I like how
long it takes to drill all right well
thank you Sean Lyons I was wondering if
you'll ever play raft insult simulator
slime rancher or stardew valley again I
guess I wouldn't mind I do like
streaming a lot more than I used to in
the past I do want to do more streams in
addition to like the normal videos that
I do like the videos being like highly
edited stuff but for things like this
where it's just like hanging out and
playing a game and just having fun
together I do like the the social aspect
of streams and it feels like you know
you sitting on the couch again and you
get like you get a lot more like
instantaneous jokes and feedback from
when you're doing like this like like
you guys with the strange conception
that there's this enormous alien gun
that got us here in the first place
laughs you know I'll have you know as a
weather balloon this shot is down to
first place not a gun but it's it's
fascinating like a lot of those old
games that I played you know it may not
work out well for a video series because
I like the video serious like videos are
something special that you put a little
extra work into or put a little extra
pizzazz it's like more of a print
okay before of a presentation was like a
livestream it's just funny AB together
all the same time and and you know I'm
streaming more on twitch I'm streaming
on here cuz I just like I like that
aspect and there's there's different
things that belong with one another and
I would like to revisit a lot of games
that I haven't given I you know it's
funny if I don't think there's a single
person here that would remember I highly
doubt it if there is please let me know
but uh way way way way way way way back
in my channel way back like this is like
the first few months I played a game
called condemned criminal criminal
origins which is a horror game and a
very good horror game that I was playing
through and it was a lot of fun and I I
got to like episode 13 of that one and I
what happened was my computer crashed
and I had to reinstall windows and I
lost the save file now this is years ago
this is like six years ago I don't know
if there's anybody here that would even
remotely remember that I don't even
think that game is uploaded to this
channel anymore that was like old
channel stuff only I'm not a hundred
percent sure but it's like I never
finished that game it's like stuck on
episode 13 and it's just like oops well
that didn't happen cuz I didn't feel
like playing through the whole game
again and I always said I would come
back to it now if you want to know about
the markiplier promise that's probably
where it started because I am through
why oh god I am now
oh god okay all right well then that
what happened okay okay all right
everything's fine everything's fine
hey look I got a message waiting for me
let's see what it is
we'll have to swim for the surface but
it's 500 meters straight up we'll make
for the rendezvous and keep you posted
out signal location uploaded to PDA know
about that I don't think I really don't
think that they're alive yeah I don't
remember what whoa hey Oh what that's
such a cool animation Hey look whole
fish Wow
all right anyway this weird still I hate
the ocean by the way did I mention you
guys I freaking hate the ocean I hate I
hate the ocean thank you no thank you
all right anyway we got stuff to do so
we're gonna get we're gonna get back to
our base over there and I don't think we
need to worry about I don't think we
need to worry about them I'm pretty sure
we've already experienced life too I do
what I'm gonna do I remember what I'm
gonna do I've got a cutie here I've got
a cutie over here I got the cutest cutie
good the cutie yeah all right so I'm
gonna take care of this cutie cutie and
that means that we are well on our way
towards getting that rocket but we're
gonna have a special friend with us for
this endeavor yeah someone said it's
gonna pop up in just a second so Bo said
I was I was talking about empty promises
and I fell into the ocean as if the game
was reminded about Zachary swickle thank
you so much for that
Sean line said I remember that game
could you please do another star D
Valley Stream I want to do stardew
valley because they're actually coming
with a multiplayer version of stardew
valley I'm not a hundred percent sure
about that but I remember hearing that
somewhere so I'm probably certain that
it's true if it's not then I'm a big
dumb dummy and that's all that matters
but right now that doesn't matter
because we have some courts which I'm
gonna turn into glass because I'm pretty
sure where's my builder tool right there
okay it's an interior dooble dang er
there it is okay glass and titanium
that's easy enough but I don't know if
Evan of Court saw me right now but I'm
gonna I'm gonna give this I don't know
how long it takes to hatch that is the
thing I don't I don't I'm not all
represent sure how long it takes a hatch
but we will see all right I hope I have
enough ports for the glass
yeah anyway so as I get this done how
you guys doing
let's see something here thank you - one
second there we are thank you - fazzy
panda say something that will make the
normies go away I know you watch boogie
that's that's nice danker supreme Jerry
hard lover light killer 87 Zachary
zwickel
Sean Lyons Frank Ellis legendary Prince
Joey
Bagga Dez nuts Niko Langford Haytham
Kenway Joe mo bio Kira Noah
Okami fr spirit thank you everybody so
much that has contributed through that
oh [ __ ] I made one too many that's all
right it's all good okay so I just need
titanium now and that is right here all
right so we're gonna build this bad boy
right in here it seems like a good place
in any yeah this kind of cuts off
traffic though so let's put you over
here Oh big boy oh yeah we're gonna need
we we need more glass to be able to
build the hatch into this thing because
that's how you get in and out of this
select carefully which life-forms you
bring on board they may also be studying
you wait what wait what
we're taken what did you say to me Karen
what why why would they I just pissed
myself what I don't like that at all
okay all right well that's terrifying
anyway let's put this egg in here all
right hang on one second let's get you
in here along with some papers oh look
at you papers oh you're gonna have a
friend oh that's awfully bulbous boink
are you uh what are you doing Oh No oh
so cute oh I can't scan you oh you're so
cute all right you be good I don't know
how long it's gonna take
oh you're so cute ooh he's so cute how
about just rest my head I'm gonna sleep
I'm gonna go to sleep and it's gonna be
great it's gonna be great oh it's gonna
be great
oh it's gonna be the cutest thing all
right uh yeah there's the shrine to my
dead bumble butt and bubble butt bubble
butt is also dead but you know win some
lose them no oh not yet not yet but soon
oh but soon oh okay so with that being
said we need to start building the
rocket now I'm not on represent sure
where I got the rocket like recipe but I
have it and that's good I don't need
that anymore so we need to build let's
see here we go we need to build the
Neptune launch platform the gantry the
Boosters the fuel reserve and the
cockpit so we got to start with the
launch platform I'm pretty sure about
that we need lead titanium ingot and a
computer chip which shouldn't be too
hard because I'm pretty sure I gathered
three eat my buttcheeks
three oh you sack of tits
yes four got it all right now we just
need a computer chip because I got the
titanium ingots right here I've got
enough of that I'm gonna need to make
plasteel ingot eventually I may have
enough for that but right now we just
need to make a computer chip how the
Frick frack do you make a computer chip
again because I've completely forgotten
table coral gold and copper wire easy
peasy
we just need to go get day before
easy-peasy give me a like goddamn knife
here all right you you give me kidney
you up hope
got that okay we got that Luba do Boop
and we got some gold and we got the
copper wire right thing two of these one
of these and we're good to go get the
copper wire going easy peasy
easy peasy mark did you shut down the
gun oh yeah sure okay
all right I shut down the gun oh wait
hang on I'm gonna turn it off everybody
hold on your horses gun I got it it's
off guys guys it's off the the guns off
okay
all right guys don't worry no that was I
was really doing it the gun is off okay
all right okay so this is good so what I
need to do is I need to go over to I
guess I'll take mr. mr. hold and I want
to take mr. Pfister mr. Pfister isn't my
preferred mode of travel but if you do
it right you know pretty speedy delije
all right now I just got to remember
where Geoffrey Billy samurais in martial
arts there you are found you come over
here hello opal ran out of juice all
right
hello friend you'd be a friend for my a
beautiful cuttlefish
all right poink all right Jeff
rebellious samurais and martial this
ain't a pretty location but you know
we're gonna do what we're gonna do okay
all right I got a job for you got real
real hefty job for you let's go
that is not okay I don't like that I
don't like that at all
you Oh oh I can pack you up hang on
Oh pack up pack it up you said I can
pack it up how do I pack it up you said
here we go
no God I'm gonna pack you up I'm gonna
pack you up watch it I'm gonna pack you
up there that worked out well
oh man I don't want to go to Life pod to
Life pod - doesn't sound fun 500 meters
whoops almost whoops okay God almost
left mr. Pfister hang on everybody
busy oh did I forget about one shot
asked Cupid the hunter no I did not it's
just that I've got so many things that I
want to do literally I've got so many
games that I want to play I I just have
to have like this priority list to go
through them now I am going on tour
again real soon so I'll be I'll be going
back to that but I I have a huge list
like I said like with the condemned
criminal origin when you do two videos a
day and you have 50 games that you want
to play it's just hard to get through
them because you have to have some sort
of semblance of a schedule and I gotta
actually put videos together in a
refreshingly normal way I suppose all
right where am I going where am I even
going I don't want to go down 500 meters
that'd be stupid how about is this good
enough this breathe deep got hefty hundo
here I probably brought deep enough
probably anyway I um I launched this up
and then I'm gonna abandon it oh so
justly right sure get rekt buddy have
fun falling to the ground all right
all right if ever there was a good place
this probably it no no all right whoops
oh there you are
all right Geoffrey Billy samurais
Marshall how about this it's good enough
just deep enough for you
there goes oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh my what
what the heck
hello wow wow wow okay Wow but alright
then my my good Jesus to his bag
that's burger all right you're telling
me something this big this huge you
talking about pissed Geoffrey Billy
Samwise and Marshall I'm so proud of you
I'm so proud of you wow this is really
something
Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall or
whatever your names are you oh my god
you guys are just an amazing amazing
group of pieces of [ __ ] I love you so
much I love you so much
Geoffrey Billy samurais are marginal you
guys are so fast extremely happy about
this all right flat stealing it copper
wire and lubricant all right let's go
get those right oh yeah whoosh Oh what
um mr. Pfister did you just refuse my
instructions to fall to the bottom of
the ocean are you okay okay
BuChE spooky spooky spooky spooky very
spooky I don't know why but very spooky
okay all right
oh boy hello thank you okay I don't want
to take mr. Pfister anymore mr. Pfister
scares me I also got to get some food
I'm probably starving okay well there's
some spooky things happening in the
ocean and I don't understand why thank
you all right I need to get another
paper Thank You GU thank you all right I
need to get another paper thank you
thank you okay let's see if let's see if
the cuttlefish is matched yet before I'm
gonna get some food in me boy all right
okay thank you to lizard mfk - sir vault
sukhino rakuen Angela Patricia vilasa
Prieto the ECM toddster mcgee edward
kenway Joe Mitchell Joe Mitchell again
Cupid the hunter
Louise serve Oni and spirit thank you
all so much cuttlefish oh you're still
growing okay it'll take some more time
let me actually do that cook those yeah
I did wash this down with some sweet
piss all right shut up god damn damn
there's so many people shouting in my
ear I don't think I have any Lube on me
that's probably the one thing that I got
to go get I need actually let me review
everything that I'm gonna need for this
bad boy am i need plasteel copper wire
lubricant class steel again class steel
I need four things of plasteel ingot s'
which if I remember how to make a
plasteel ingot it's a titanium ingot and
lithium right isn't that it titanium and
lithium
do I even have enough lithium I have any
lithium lithium lithium or something
else maybe they change that but I'm not
I represent sure yeah to lithium okay
I'm gonna need to get more lithium I
have enough titanium to make the other
plasteel ingot but I am gonna need to
get lube and I need a lot of Lube yeah
all right boo boo Boop got that all
right let's go get some Lube all right I
think there's a force just to the south
of here going by hand why aren't I
taking bubble butt I'm such an idiot I
mean I love my seagull ID I really do
but bubble Oh bubble gum sorry bubble
butt is dead sorry you're dead a long
time you were very dead all right we're
almost there were almost there we're
doing great guys doing great guys thank
you do Jess crew and Chuck again if you
don't tour to Canada eventually us
Canadians will be pissed okay all right
I need to tour in a place called Canada
okay all right well it's Canada the
place where this enormous alien gun is
right yeah okay well we'll tour in
Canada okay you guys are out of your
gourds you guys are out of your gourds
are you are you because you seem to be
clearly out of your
you guys seem to be clearly out of your
gourds okay
all right we'll go we'll go to a place
called Canada sure okay guys yeah all
right you guys are so hilarious man I
love you guys I love you guys but yeah
you need to you need to try to stop
pulling fast ones on me I know there
ain't no gun and I know there ain't no
country called Canada okay I went to
elementary school I was very close to
being an engineer I think I know a thing
or two about what countries exist and
what guns are real you guys just need
that cool your jets there yeah no wait
no it's a real gun I turned it off oh
okay all right all right so I got that
let's make some Lube let's make some
Lube let's make up some Lube Lube oh
yeah all right
ba ba ba give it give me your Lube gonna
be all death there we go we're gonna
make more Lube than we need I don't know
Mims because if you feel like it I guess
all right let's see thank you Bob
Thank You Erin Turner dc-3 II Asian mega
zero Thank You Patrick Thiessen Josh
Baron blot Evan Stacy thank you all so
much but again not necessary not
necessary at all please don't please
please I don't need it it's all good all
right I'm sufficiently lubed up I think
that's only need for that Oh copper wire
okay just a little copper large it's a
little Oh just a little bit not it's not
the copper container here we go just a
little bit of baby copper wire okay and
then we should have what we need to be
able to do what we need to do thank you
to Bob aka lapis put my name on one of
the lockers within the rocket I don't
know if there are lockers within the
rocket but I guess you asked so a maybe
I'll think about it
not I represent you sure about that take
it to a sit I'll let Alex know briefs
and DC 3e who said turn the gun back on
oh okay all right I'll turn the gun back
on
wait hang on wait finagle it guns back
on guys book the guns back on I got it
don't worry about that the guns back on
okay all right it's gonna shoot us down
do you guys wait hey God guys all right
this is just clear the air where uh
where is a gun you guys see a gun here
no if it was as big as you say it is if
it was big enough to shoot down that
Aurora which was sabotaged by the way it
was sabotage and we all saw it was fine
it made a landing and then it blew up
because of a reactor overload that's
that's why that happened I think I would
see a gun around here capable of
shooting me down you guys turn it off
turn off the gun okay Oh turn it off
when I'm dead okay anyway all right so
the Boosters would be next nickel or
aerogel how do I make aerogel I don't
even know how to make aerogel I'm sure
the fabricators gonna tell me you know
whatever it's big it's big baby oh it's
a big one
whoa wait is there something on the side
of that Oh what are you what are you
what are you Oh
oh yeah oh yeah yeah I'm gonna dive off
of you
oh I'm gonna dive off you think I'm
gonna die guys do you think I'm gonna
die hey hang on wait wait good place
your beds clear your butt ow
I am toughen a little bit didn't even
hurt
didn't hurt didn't hurt at all all right
oh you silly silly people okay where did
their your hope sploosh
dive right into my C Mon because that's
how much of a badass I am all right
so the next one we need nickel ore and
then arrow Joe now I don't know how to
make aerogel but I'm pretty sure this
game is gonna tell me I don't know if
I'll have the materials to make aerogel
but I've got pretty much every material
that I could ever want in this game so I
don't know we'll see what happens thank
you to Draco Phoenix Evan Stacey MD
Baldridge Angela Patricia Filosa Prieto
Thank You Jacob Sperry Jeff Eider splash
TW Ashley Burrell zambie killer gaming
dragon lady Michael Harris Zachary
zwickel thank you all so much
okay aerogel it's got to be in the
advance yeah gel sack oh I know where
that is I do I know where that is I know
where that is um my my my my my mom gel
sack is actually right nearby it is
right cuz it's that edible thing okay I
do know about that but I'm gonna take a
little nap cuz it's nighttime and I
don't want to go down to the door
I don't want it dude I don't want to do
that I don't want to do that that sounds
like a terrible thing to do all right
unless I just slept so they'd start but
I also I'm sleeping just to see if the
cuttlefish is there because if the
cuttlefish is there I'm gonna be super
happy about that I pissed myself
Oh cuttlefish cuttlefish cuttlefish
you're so cute
hello oh you've got a permanent smile
just like chica oh oh [ __ ] me he's mr.
scope sorry I'm sorry I'm okay God oh
man oh god it's so cute and so alright
so cute that's so cute so cute alright
where is this cuttlefish a small gray
colored herbivore the cuttlefish
displays high levels of intelligence
curiosity and attachment strangely the
species has not been encountered in the
wild and scan specimen had to be
artificially asked within an alien
containment unit in the absence of wild
specimens gluten can be known for
certain about the cuttlefish lifecycle
it is possible that the environmental
conditions have changed forcing the
species to the edge of extinction
oh and leaving its eggs in permanent
stasis it's also possible that the
cuttlefish has been genetically altered
or even imported two four five or six be
from another world behavior we do know
that the cuttlefish is an herbivore
which displays highly social behavior
see you I'll call you Calvin mmm Calvin
the cuttlefish
as was observed in earth dolphins before
their extinction this creature seems to
understand the concept of other minds
the prime indicator of true sentience in
attempts to communicate with a series of
chirps and chops
suggests the cuttlefish is capable of
understanding to follow simple commands
in addition to assessing the emotional
state of individuals around it and
spawning in kind motion connection
between living creatures is an essential
component of psychological health oh my
god that is too freaking cute I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die I could die right now
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die and I'm glad
those two peepers have decided to to
repopulate cuz man they got busy sorry
Calvin oh look at Calvin dancing I love
you I love you I love you alright anyway
sorry back to the task at hand I need to
go get some gosh darn ah I need to get a
gel sack I'm gonna get a sack Oh got it
I know it's in the crevasse here you
gotta go down to the cross to get some
sacks oh that's so good what is that
what
a bag of piss drink that piss that
fizzbin no oh wait did I drop that
before I think I have a vague memory I
dropped that oh I found my piss guys
yeah I found the bag of pee that I was
waiting for buddy don't worry don't
worry about it don't worry about nothing
everybody get ready yeah I'd like to
think that like instead of like shirts
and [ __ ] like that you know shirts I'd
like you know how Elon Musk is selling
the flamethrower I'd like to have
special markiplier merch that's out of
the ordinary it's everybody who
subscribes to my channel gets a free bag
of piss is it like to say I'm not saying
it's mine neither it's just generic like
chica it's it's chica pee oh god I don't
I wish I hadn't said anything at all I
wish I had shut my goddamn mouth before
had an opportunity to ruin the
experience forever
no I'm doubling down on this everybody
that subscribes in the next 24 hours I
will ship a bag of piss to your house
right now that's right you two can be
the proud owner of a bag of piss so if
you just subscribe limited supplies so
please please get them while you can
all right yeah now I wish I shut up now
I definitely wish I shut up all right
where's these gel sacs where are these
goddamn sacks of [ __ ] I thought they
were down here right they were
supposedly I remember getting one from
over here unless I've farmed him out I
don't know guys do you know where the
gel sacs are unsubscribed nope if you if
you unsubscribe ah some kind of
punishment what's what's a piss related
punishment Oh was that
that's a creature egg I don't need that
if you unsubscribe it's too late
everybody that's already been subscribed
the the pisses on the way to your house
right now so don't even try to avoid it
it's on the way if you unsubscribe and
will only get there faster and double in
supply so just be careful about that I
can't control these things it's pretty
much black magic that controls it hey
Watchers but watch yourself where's the
gel sex guys where's the gel sacks the
sacks are in the Koosh that doesn't seem
right
I don't believe that at all grand reef
come on oh I don't want to go to the
grand reef I don't want to go to the
grand reef whoo sure
okay Koosh I'm gonna go Koosh I'm gonna
go I'm go some sweet coos all right it
better be in the couch zone you guys
better not be lying to me there anything
else is there anything else any from the
couch take Calvin out I will maybe in a
second oh wait I can actually see I can
actually see subscribers I'm gonna look
at just subscribers for a moment here
yeah everybody who's gonna get a bag of
piss they use sand drag or snake Joe
gardener dude face Liam Oren gamer axe
man MK Hughton Oliver Thompson potato
gaming Anthony walnuts Renee Luna
Michael Silver Wing bunny Jay King
autumn good body Canadian bacon you're
all getting back to piss oh yeah
everybody that has taken part of this
very limited offer okay you don't want
to miss out you don't want to be the guy
on your street without a patented
markiplier baguette piss so no mean boy
matter sonic Rick Pat a normal gamer
warrior kale bleed Xander Newman bad
company Yoshi Jay aren't monk old fender
nup purple son Austin cats person Auto
sajevic sachet ovitch ever gay scarf
Joran on XY terran master Michael
Shelley James Dixon duck Magoo you don't
want to miss out okay limited time offer
I'm exciting because supplies are so
limited only the people in the next
let's say two hours we'll be able to get
their patented bag of piss don't miss
out where are these goddamn gel sex not
the none of these things I'm looking for
gel sex I don't like this guys where's
the gel sacs so you take Calvin I'll I
will I will I'll take Calvin out for a
walk real soon but I don't see no gel
sacks what's that no that's a ruby hey
hmm don't like it don't send people piss
wait what what are you talking about
don't are you saying that people don't
want that are you honestly saying that
people don't want me to send them a bag
of piss out of your gourd as well okay
all right whatever you know I don't
think okay people don't want my [ __ ]
all right you know I'll put that right
up with with the whole Canada country
whatever that is and that there is a
giant gun that's gonna shoot down my
rocket you guys you guys always pull in
my leg you know that's the one thing I
like about livestreams you guys always
get a chance to pull my leg and one of
these days you're gonna fool me one of
these days you're gonna fool me but that
day is not today
all right people want this people want
people want to believe there's a country
called Canada and and people believe
there's a giant gun that's gonna shoot
me down okay why hasn't it shot me down
already
if there is a giant gun why isn't it not
shot me down boy answer me that question
why is it only gonna shoot me down when
I supposedly build a rocket huh yeah
that doesn't make any sense
yeah if we if there was a darn gun we
would have seen it by now
okay all right
or where's the gel sacks I don't say no
gel sack am I gonna have to look this up
am I gonna have to look this up Thank
You xeo that's all illuminate ryx SDC
resurrection no coconuts game Snow White
mr. happy Addison Maya the fan of malaya
Thaxton Gonzalo Galindo Shawn Cena kim
ramirez arctic den it's updated again
bro Salada miss nature yeti land cup had
the drawer every my te conex paper jam
pirate Fox gamer Nick back Herc is Lee
bondrock Lily the wolf Alden abullah
frikar dairy and cartons of golden
gaming Dominic tomorrow Evan get no pro
gamer 21 inch Rob Jacob Thomas you are
all getting packs of purse oh yeah it's
gonna be in it's gonna be like a plushie
just don't bag up is alright anyway no
it's gonna be real all right I don't
know where this goddamn gel sacs are you
have a gel sack well how in the world
how's that help me okay how's that help
me huh
how's that help me okay how's that how
in the world does that help me I'm a
look up where a gel sack is because yeah
I just don't trust you I don't trust
that's a sound okay alright where where
in the heck is a gel sack blood blood
kelp bone fields grand reef deep grand
reef dunes sinkhole Chili's room loss
river mushroom forest esparza brief
mushroom forest wait mushroom forest it
says I'm in a mushroom force right now
let's see if it's there and everybody
hold onto your horses I'm looking for
jail sex I just need two of them I'm
pretty sure that because I only need
aerogel for the next thing and then
nothing else right I'm pretty sure
aerogel yeah I only need know I need
four of them to be safe maybe two
okay keep your peepers peeled keep your
papers filled is gonna be wild and crazy
keep your papers bailed oh [ __ ]
good yeah is that it Joel sick that's
not a jealous
[Music]
No Oh God my bubblegum is very damaged
get out get up
please don't send me Pete you want poop
Oh gross get out here oh you sick
disgusting person poop
Oh gross I have poop in my inventory
right now see I'm not even line I got
poop right here you know why you don't
want it you don't want that nobody wants
that look gross get out of here oh I
can't believe so many people you know we
were all having fun and games about how
there's a there's a there's a there's a
there's our alien gun and there's a
country called Canada and if people
don't want piss but gross you know some
people just take it too far how people
don't let us have fun I don't see any
gel sexes ooh no that's an air Bowl damn
it I am incredibly stupid I am
incredibly stupid I'm incapable of
having any normal social interactions
I am socially inept I have way too high
an opinion of myself and I can't find
any gel sacks there that's all my flaws
that's every flaw that I have right now
there I said it got it out in the open
now I'll make fun of me whatever I don't
even care anymore
my brother cam where the goddamn L of
these gels eggs I don't even know I
could have sworn that I found him before
but they must have changed the location
up because I am at a complete loss okay
whoa how did I get so far away all right
I need to go to the grand reef because
it's the only place you can plant gel
sex
I keep passing them no no no you lie all
right wait hang on we're gonna play a
game you say warmer or colder we go real
slow all right that's not a gel Zack I
know that they're like they're they're a
dark like gray blue oh that people
sleeping
or is that people dead that peepers dead
isn't it that it's sleepy
oh no it's sleeping it was sleeping ah I
startled it it's blind apparently no sir
I didn't even know that they slept
didn't you know that they slept know
that they slept it off all right you go
warmer colder warmer colder warm colder
cold warmer what is that it's an alien
egg cold warmer warm cold cold warm warm
cold this isn't helping at all you guys
are absolutely out of your goddamn minds
yeah they're bioluminescent thereby
they're bioluminescent they're
bioluminescent i think i think ii think
i think a lanka thong key i think he
funcle' UNK yeah okay it says it's in
this in like these areas but I don't
think it's in this one anyway I'm gonna
go back and I'm gonna go to the deep
grand reef because that's where I gotta
go I can't believe I can't believe I got
a hunt around for this [ __ ] again
hey I get it I get it I have to go to
the grand reef I get it I understand I
know it's fine I got it
oh all right I'm gonna take mr. Fisher
because a bubble gum doesn't have the
depth module for so God's sake mr.
Pfister oh all right fine then yeah
thank you everybody who subscribed you
are going to don't worry your bags of
piss are in the mail currently all right
let's get out of here uh how y'all doing
how y'all doing on the Tree of Life
well I'm not gonna go all the way down
there oh the big boy and then I'm not
gonna go all the way over there either I
know there's probably some goddamn sacks
somewhere over in the yonder way and I'm
gonna find it on my own it's all good
I'm not worried about it
ohyeah wait where am I going again I
don't have my mr. Fisher as like a
landmark down there anymore so it's kind
of hard to judge exactly where I need to
go Missy you know what see piss well it
takes like three to five days to mail
you got to give a little patience for it
I can't I can't I can't just get it to
you immediately
you guys gotta wait for the scanner room
that's what that thing is for
oh yeah
the whole scanner room thing that's what
it's for finding things ah yes yes
indeed that is the point of that isn't
it ah yes I'm stupid I'm incredibly dumb
right I have a room dedicated to finding
[ __ ] ah oh ah ha I do
ah any more lithium I saw
[Music]
it's fine it's all right everybody hold
on here or Zyzz it's fine
okay it's totally fine ah all right
I've been missing some super chats I'm
gonna go back to looking at super chat
mode cuz I don't wanna I don't want to
miss out on that uh yeah yeah okay thank
you to bulb at Saget Ari Dakota Foxx boo
boo ninja it's just a lot of people that
saying that I need to send them piss
which is very strange I don't know what
you're talking about
also boo boo nerd who said the cannon is
non cannon
I like the way you think yeah thank you
- Griffin fire gel sacs are found on the
blood kelp zone in the walls bone fields
came grand reef debrief sinkhole village
yeah I'm on the way to the deep grand
reef right now which is where I'm gonna
find most of them Shane piles John pail
Pelkey tile zero ounce hallo Alan
coswell anime Jonas Matty Rick Pat sink
bust cat cat who said give me a big old
bag of piss well people demand it got to
do what people demand what about this
area this area seems like a place for
Saxon Jill ooh yeah what about down here
wasn't there why wasn't there stuff down
here I don't remember what these this
place is called but yes yes yes that's a
sack jell-o that's a sack gel all right
it's down here yes yes I see more yeah
yes I don't even know what these this
place is called but you should be cured
all right you you need to be cured I
don't know why you're not cured but you
should be cheap
yes yes yes oh yes yes yes indeed okay
all right I got my gel sex I need one
more just one more one more sweet Sachi
jell-o event okay right that sonic gel
so you oh you're a creature egg okay
you'd be cute I guess whatever you are
what about behind me sack of gel no how
about up here yes
whoa hey whoa whoa mr. Pfister hey calm
down there calm down there okay I got
these that's enough all right I'm Audi
I'm Audi baby shooting through the roof
yes yes yes yes oh no no no squeeze okay
so now I'm on the way back I got
everything I need I need I have enough
to be able to build this and I should be
good all right Magdalene fear of ledge
says I'm gonna flip my chair and myself
with it if that cannon shoots you on the
way to space what are you talking about
all right yeah okay how okay how how
would a cannon shoot me out like a
rocket is moving like super fast and any
sort of gun like if I fired a bullet at
like a space shuttle it wouldn't reach
it it's it's not gonna work it just
doesn't go fast enough I don't know no
you're talking about it it just doesn't
make sense just think think about it
rationally there's no way there's no way
there's no way like I'm sorry but
there's I am alright yeah let me get a
look good look at you I hate mr. Pfister
I really do
alright did someone tell him about the
gun is real yeah they tried they tried
look I get the whole conspiracy thing
it's it's da word it's not worth it's
alright subhana is my favorite series of
yours by the way pay attention to the
credits says Dale large ok I will I'm
gonna let the whole credits play because
it's a fascinating thing like in the
what has it been like two years three
years since this game has been in
development in early access like this
game is one of the few games that really
really LEDs lend some credit to the
whole early access concept it's it's and
I don't know who the leadership team on
this but it's just really really
fascinating that they see it's really
heartwarming to see what what people are
willing to do like as far as just
putting their their their time and
effort into building something and
always adding on top of it no matter how
hard it is to go back and redo some of
the work which they have like the team
in subnautica is like redone so much
[ __ ] in here and it's just really
heartwarming to see like what they've
been able to do and how far they've been
able to come it's it's really cool and I
wish that more games were able to do
this I wish that more games took the
early access thing like and made
something special out of it like I know
minecraft was one of the first ones and
that's like another example of like
doing early access right and I know you
guys probably have suggestions of other
games that have done early access
correctly but men it's just really it's
really cool to see how far this game has
come and also like it doesn't end with
this like I know that they have other
planned like additions to the game like
they're gonna keep going with it and
like the main story that they wanted to
tell it has come and gone like with this
game and it's just really cool to see
like I just wanted to like say that real
quick because I know I'm talking about
all the piss and whatnot and joking
around and this game is super fun to
joke around with and it's a very good
vehicle for just like hanging out and
having a conversation but you know it's
really cool to see and and I applaud the
effort of any
game development companies and tries you
know that hard to make something special
cuz you don't see it very often oh wait
alright what did I need I've aerogel
that's right I need something Ruby Ruby
that's what I needed not the show the
thing the thing that I need rubies
I have rubies right over here because I
farmed up a bunch of them when they
needed it Ruby all right let's make some
aerogel baby let's make some Aerojet I
only need one alright whatever it's all
right so good okay so I got two of those
what else do I need I need the nickel or
and a wiring kit I have both of those I
know I do
nickel or it's not there it's over here
no nickel or there we go and a wiring
kit oh I gotta get rid of this poop
sorry
shut that poop in there all right I need
a wiring kit which I believe is right
here yes okay and then what else I need
more nickel one more nickel and boom
baby is that all I needed
see yep that's all I needed all right
whoa let's get out there all right so we
have everything we need
all right let's go out it let's do this
Calvin you want to see Calvin oh yeah
let's bring Calvin outside let's take a
little Calvin break we've been working
so hard oh yeah Calvin Calvin whoa these
peoples have gotten busy well I should
build another one on top of this to make
like a tall thing inventory full oh let
me drink some proofs glug glug glug glug
and I can eat these I know I can I've
got those piss all right we're good
we're yeah there you are whoa okay Kelly
we're gonna go outside we're gonna go
outside don't mind being in my pocket
while we're in the not water but
all right Calvin go bird oh I hope there
wasn't an eat bunny Oh Calvin play with
fish oh you want a treat
oh it's gone oh so smart you're so smart
Calvin oh my god Oh Calvin Calvin Calvin
Oh Calvin
oh all right Calvin
all right you don't word Calvin oh
they're here Calvin all right hey Calvin
all right you you stay whoa oh there you
are all right you stay here I don't want
you go I'm going somewhere dangerous I
don't want you to be a problem I don't
want you to be problem huh I'm gonna
protect Calvin with my life I'll go
protect album with my life my life yes
wait
wait hang on neurons are firing ideas
are connect everybody wait is there a
way to pick Calvin back up is it it's
your way to pick Calvin wait wait hang
on I got I have to have them in my
inventory to be able to bring them to
space but if I can't pick them up here
wait I yeah hang on wait yeah yeah no
hang on wait oh wait wait wait but but
but no but but wait this is way to put
there's a way to put a burn
hello hello wait wait but but wait but
wait
no wait okay
we don't know anything yet where my
brain just took a lot of time to piece
that together you know wait yeah
wherever we Geoffrey Billy samurais
Marshall you guys get to business
right click we'll just command to follow
but I don't think oh well let's not
panic yet let's not panic yet
Louise wise says mechanical engineers
greater than civil engineers in math and
physics the trajectory of the projectile
can hit a moving object like a rod
rocket no biomedical engineers above all
other engineers like and I say no I was
almost a biomedical engineer I was
almost wow wow wow that's big that's big
I didn't know how big this thing was
gonna be whoa this is like so big all
right what do I need for the next round
I need the fuel booster crystalline
sulfur kyanite I think I have both of
those ion power cell good thing good
thing I grabbed kyanite while I was I
was still there all right we don't know
anything yet we don't know anything yet
well I don't know anything yet I'm
incredibly stupid we don't know we don't
know if we're gonna leave Calvin behind
we don't know that we don't know that we
don't know that so might as well not
panic and it's fine it's fine it's fine
hey Calvin come here hey Calvin hey
Calvin there we go
Alvin Alvin didn't get in my pocket okay
we don't know anything yet
we're not know anything yet we don't
know anything yet we don't know anything
yet we don't know anything yet
propulsion cannon yes yes the the the
propulsion cannon yes I can pick Calvin
up and then throw them into the ship
yes propose again yeah that might work
okay yeah okay sure yeah no three
kyanite no just three three three
I need four maybe there's someone
big-box berry hang on everybody hang on
a second no oh no I had C crown no no
that's the secret I dropped off three
three Oh No there was a gel sack in
their own
there's only one place to get kyanite
it's all the way back down oh no oh that
sucks
oh that sucks so badly why didn't I get
one more kyanite I don't have a depth
module oh no oh no oh why is there an
eye washer an ion cell in there ah God
break my balls oh wait maybe that's some
rare stuff sir maybe a UH oh we got some
rare OHS ooh this looks promising
there's a lot of piss in that one oh
[ __ ]
huh proposed to Gannon hey that's handy
dandy whoa a cyclops efficiency module
that's handy alright so that's nice come
on one
[Music]
did I miss did I miss it
did I miss it was it there where that's
a diamond that's not kyanite did I miss
it no it's not there that's diamond
break my balls
where's kyanite oh god just kill me kill
me kill me kill me just kill me kill me
just straight-up stab me in the neck
just kill me okay
just kill me all right kill me just
straight-up stabbed me in my neck kill
me
I pissed myself thank you to everybody
that's been donating through super chat
kill me kill me drain me of my blood all
right okay there's a chance there's a
very slim chance there's a very slim
chance it's very small but there's a
very slim chance I believe I can get a
kyanite at like just barely 900 meters
kill me kill me so hard
Oh kill me all right if I'm to be if I
if I'm to believe this correctly I
believe this is actually a landmark to
the blood kelp zone that's gonna lead me
down into the depths of hell I should
probably take care of that but then
again I did shout kill me so I'm gonna
I'm gonna shove this entire Spade fish
in my mouth that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna shove this entire Spade fish in my
mouth my efforts
[ __ ] ping comic alright and I'm gonna
save real quick cuz I'm about Tess's
propulsion Canon on this isn't alright
this might kill Kelvin this might might
not be as good as I think it is hang on
wait I'm just gonna pick Calvin up it's
gonna been delicately alright hi Calvin
don't mind me Calvin hang on I've got
Calvin
[Music]
he didn't happen it didn't happen it
didn't happen didn't happen everybody
shut up
didn't happen it didn't happen didn't
happen didn't happen didn't happen it
didn't happen that didn't happen
nobody saw anything everybody did Shawn
nothing didn't happen Calvin's fine
see wait Calvin's fine where are you
Calvin Darrius he's fine he's fine he's
fine he's fine see comments mine
Calvin's fine
Calvin's fight now that's fun now that's
fine
Calvin is fine no one worry
Calvin is fine didn't make another
shrine to kill let's get rid of this
horrible monstrosity and never never
talk about that ever again let's just
never talk about that let's that didn't
happen guys it just didn't happen weird
there's a gap in my memory didn't happen
it didn't happen
who'da thunk 'old that definitely did
not happen
no no no guys no no I didn't kill Calvin
that's not what happened
you guys saw something different that's
ridicul blanked out for a second you got
in the world where there is a gun and
you guys just went absolutely crazy out
of your mind
but stuff this in my gob to shove this
whole Spadefish right in there
plump yum delicious how about you two
mr. Spade fish all right everything's
fine these guys good Eaton's oh really
oh that's all right see fine it's good
you know why because I wouldn't do that
I just wouldn't nope that's not I
wouldn't do that
no stop pressing after payers backs cuz
Calvin is fine and alive
Calvin is alive and fine Calvin's find
Calvinist but we all saw Calvin is fine
in fact even if that did supposedly
happen in your weird world where that
happened no no no no Calvin's fine in
that weird world if that were to be the
case I didn't see a dead body nobody saw
a dead body and everybody knows in any
show TV show movie and let videogame
unless you see a dead body they're not
dead so I don't even know what you're
talking about because number one that
didn't happen
number two nobody so yeah you can take
your conspiracy theories and just shove
shove them hard anywhere just feel free
go go to shove town with that because it
didn't happen did not happen in any way
shape or form and you're crazy for
thinking it did you know don't want you
to worry about a single thing ever so
just let me worry about what you're
worrying about
and everything's gonna be just fine
right right
no stop pressing f is fine Calvin this
is redeye critics and you can't fool me
you killed cab think that you can be the
judge of anything you guys are watching
this like Minh this supposedly live okay
yeah this is live whatever but you know
don't think anyone can prove whoopsies
I'm rich stabbing you now apparently all
right it's fine you know what yeah you
guys had your fun your silliness we all
had a good laugh at my expense fine
nothing to stop pressing f it didn't
know you guys saw nothing nothing
happened Hey I don't remember ever
seeing this live plot actually yeah I
don't remember ever seeing this light
bud have I seen this one weird no it's
new
new PDA flotation devices failed we're
flooding evacuate wait I can reconfigure
the o2 system to act as a bilge pump
it's working okay good news we're alive
and we've stopped sinking bad the
oxygens going to run out in 30 minutes
and we're 500 meters down what do we do
we'll have to use the remaining juice to
send a distress call and build whatever
gear we can then we find a way to the
surface huh
I'm guessing they didn't make it that's
just my hypothetical guess here all
right so now that now that we got that
out of the way I know this is this is
definitely the one that leads down so
I'm just gonna go down we're gonna find
us some kyanite you guys are gonna stop
being silly and stop being silly all
right stop being silly and we're just
gonna we're gonna have a good old time
everything's fine no no no no no you
know we all have fun here we have fun
it's a fun time you know I just fancy
so I guess this is the way that they
wanted me to go to go down to the Lost
River which is all well and good like it
fine enough
spider-man okay huh all right what do
you want from me guys do you want me to
admit it you want me to admit it and at
best it was manslaughter it was cuddle
slaughter it was Calvin slaughter that
sounds worse but you know that's what it
was it wasn't premeditated okay
admittedly I did like scare Adam pull
him close hold them in the propulsion
cannon and then okay all right this it's
it's awfully suspicious all right it is
suspicious I will give you that it is
very very suspicious I would it's it's
like it's enough it's enough to raise an
investigation I'll give you that I will
give you that it is definitely conundrum
as' oh god it's not oh it's too deep no
it's too deep what the kyanite it's over
there and I need this guy to be able to
get it oh no it's gonna be just a hair
too deep isn't it okay I think I can
navigate this I think I can fix this if
I do this right I can land on there cuz
it I believe that's just below 500
meters 900 meters I'm either gonna blow
up mr. Pfister or we're gonna get this
kind of excuse me well we're gonna get
this kyanite baby
we're gonna get this we're gonna give
this kind of okay all right I don't
think it's gonna work
but this is the only method I got cuz I
I bet I bet I would have had enough I
bet I wouldn't have enough I I bet I
would have had enough to be able to get
what I need I bet I would have enough
and I think it'll last long enough to be
able to get it and get out
especially if I'm able to vote this way
especially if I'm able to get just
enough I bet if I land on right on the
tip of that vent there that's gonna be
in the right range okay all right this
is where we're gonna save because it's
gonna get dangerous I got to get down
there I know there's kyanite on the way
down I know there is and I know you have
to drill it you have to drill it there's
no other way you have to drill it so if
I can combine the two hoop I can land on
that tree I can definitely land on that
tree the very tippy top II of that tree
something I can land on okay please tell
me I can land on this oh very close
almost there hippity-hoppity whoo okay
it's fine okay I know
let me scout it out first let me scout
it out I know that this guy and I down
here I just don't know how far down it
is
and I believe no [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh come on
Wow it's hot it's too hot I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine
Oh No
ouchies that's real hot Oh Howie okay
all right well I have myself I bet it
wouldn't have even taken all that much
material to be able to make the freaking
depth module for the freakin wait no is
it this piss [ __ ] piss and [ __ ] all
right I'm just gonna go for it could be
a bad idea but I'm gonna get it go I
don't like that sound oh hey how is
going buddy okay it's fine it's fine
it's fine I got this I got this all
right I got this okay
where is mr. Pfister there's mr. Pfister
all right let's see how quickly it's
gonna kill me let's do this in and out
super speedy like all I need to do is
harvest it I just have to harvest it
here we go all right we're fine okay
I just gotta get to it and crack it
that's all I have to do I have to get to
it and crack it that's it come on grab
something you bastard
grab something get kyanite kyanite come
on what limited time
hey get out of here I'm not infected
anymore oh [ __ ] come on where the hell
well there used to be kyanite all over
the place here why suddenly no kyanite
where the Frick frack
we're the where's the freaking kyanite
where is it where is it
no where is it why is it not here it
used to be all over the place we're
gonna die we're gonna die we're gonna
die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I am on a diet
I'm on a diet
I am on a diet I'm on a diet is how I
die is how I die oh guy night there
there there I saw it I saw it I saw it
oh come on come on you laggy bastard
come on you laggy bastard come on ooh
just crack it they're gonna crack it yes
just one just one sweet kyanite there it
is there we go okay it's in there
let's see if we can get up in time oh I
don't know if I can repair faster than
the damage is being done but I can try
okay take a break breather
get the thing back up okay go
okay 32 all this that's bad
hey scary scary scary I don't think
we're gonna make it I'm gonna try to
repair it why am I going I'm going
backwards why am I going backwards why
am i going backwards wait wait wait wait
wait what what what why what is
happening okay alright yes that made no
progress why okay I'm gonna try repair
it but try I bet I don't know if I can
repair faster than this I can I can okay
okay
okay and I'm gonna take I'm gonna take
the kyanite out of here just in case
okay all right this is the most
stressful thing that I've ever seen in
my life okay that should be enough what
my jet isn't real oh my jet hasn't
recharged yet okay that's fine
sure we'll go with sure you charge
recharge recharge recharge recharge
recharge okay hope let's get out of here
try to find some elevation yeah I don't
like the squonk did I get turned around
did I did I somehow get dude I honestly
really god [ __ ] damnit how the hell
did I get turned around how how did that
happen how in the hell did that happen
okay I gotta get out and repair again
I'm gonna hop out prepare okay hello
this is [ __ ]
beyond [ __ ] this is beyond the
[ __ ] oh my god
piss myself
okay let's guy I'm facing the right
direction I swear I am let's go this way
prepare rejuvenate okay
34 I think we're gonna make it I think
not I represent sure but I think we're
gonna make it oh man if the lag would
stop that degree come on
22 dad's fine it's fine
okay come on come on oh you have tea
baby oh so much lag why is this lagging
like crazy I don't know why here all
right I'm a repair just in case
hey ye huh I'm gonna have a heart attack
nicely I've already take you most
stressful thing I've ever done in my
entire life
and we outie we out he okay
we outie we outie it's lagged like crazy
huh yeah all right
and oh my god
all that for one one kinda all that for
one kyanite oh okay
alright let's carry on like none of that
ever I sure hope I don't have to get
another special material somehow
conveniently for
so how you guys doing you good you guys
good
you guys having a good time you guys
entertained cuz that's what this is all
about right just too entertaining you
guys I know I know those beer bull crap
I know because I endured it oh my god
alright the Bonefish ministry use you uh
huh it's Gary
oh my god the lag is so real you know
they did optimize this game a little bit
but it's still not quite so good
especially when you're loading between a
lot of biomes now I got to get back
before I starve to death
oh yeah I did it I did it I can't
believe I did it either you know I can't
believe they moved the kyanite that far
in but you know what I am just too damn
persistent I will not be thwarted I will
not be turned away at the door I will
get what I came for
or I will blow everything up and kill
Calvin I know Karen I know I know I know
ooh this is food the gel sacs are food
that's good food good eats good eats
good eats
all right good eats good
man I tell you what I tell you what this
has been I'll save the game that's
probably a good idea oh I'll yield do
your wisdom ooh
lag got the game is super laggy right
now that's how you turn around it just
flips you around like that
huh hey hey how's it going I am stressed
beyond all imagination I just need a
second to take a breather
thank you Giga oblivion Alfredo muy
triste in all Calvin's
[Music]
that's ominous and loud
okay that isn't the most thumping
ominous music I've ever heard in the
game I don't know what is I don't like
but I think it's okay you Shh you should
escape this game sure likes to dick with
me alright before I head back I'm
actually gonna look at the blueprints
that's still scary still scary uh thank
you didn't the on cat demos Cat Cat evil
Morty Sean McLaughlin Thank You Larry
Moritz Viet Camrose Chandler as your
shaft app maze them with legend of the
lethal Titan thank you all for the super
chat I really appreciate it I'll read in
more details soon all right
PLAs steel Power Cell enamelled glut and
then we'll glass I'm just gonna steal
this Cyclops shield generator out of the
Cyclops that's all I'm gonna do okay but
I just need an amble that's fine that's
okay
at least that's predictable and just
punch one of the one of the Raptor
bastards in the teeth I'll drill it out
of them
our right Karen if you say so vital
signs stabilizing okay so we just need
to make the plasteel ingot and then
we're good to go
oh yeah yeah okay why are you yeah
you're freaking sick I can't do anything
to help you go get some poop or puke
from one of the sea Emperor babies I'm
becoming a natural bear grylls why by
drinking so much of my own piss is that
what it is man proudest moment I'm gonna
use you to leapfrog forward okay where
are we all right so I just I need I
think I need bubble butt to be able to
get the teeth out of those little Raptor
dudes I forget what their names are I
can't even remember yeah ah shut up go
away I don't want to bother with you God
I you know I hate mr. Pfister so much I
can't wait to get rid of mr. Pfister
because mr. Pfister is just the most
annoying sack of [ __ ] this is the method
of travel even after I've gotten in jail
I have the jet upgrade I do but god this
son of a [ __ ] it's just so so annoying
alright let me see if the UH let me see
if these guys will come white mr.
Pfister in the ass and maybe maybe
that'll be good enough to get some teeth
out of the deal yeah yeah yeah I'll get
your intake can I eat the kelp I think I
can eat the kelp can I
think I can yeah oh yeah oh yeah hey you
who your disease are your teeth just
practically falling out here bite me
bite me bite my ass here come on bite it
bite it bite my ass bite my ass
come on bite my ass bite it come on oh
shut up Karen bite it
no they're not able to bite this I don't
think they're able to get a nibble on it
alright yeah I got to get bubblegum for
this bubblegum is required good honestly
I don't want to deal with mr. Pfister
any more than I have to thank you XX 9 9
X 9 8 x x.b 10 AR love your video man's
here some green leaves thank you very
much I really appreciate it thank you
weirdly Meg hellhound weirdly Meg said
all aboard the note boat hellhound said
you are awesome are thank you guys so
much
now all right all right okay all right
okay this has been going well there's
been going well
there's been no problems so far there's
a been a flawless run I've done nothing
wrong
I have defied the odds nobody important
has died and look Steve Calvin hey
Calvin
that's gone Calvin hey Calvin good to
see ya good to see it Cowboys Derek how
it's fine everyone's gonna like that
that's not Calvin that's like Malvin or
something like does it replace me it's
like we're your parents when you you're
like goldfish dies but they don't tell
you they just replace the goldfish and
like it's just a little bit different
than the other one just like mom I think
something's different about Calvin is
like that's Calvin that's Calvin all
right yeah I don't worry about I'm gonna
eat some of you know nom nom Oh get
ready to get ate all right yeah it's
it's Melvin it's it's trowel then yeah
that's Calvin all right okay yeah
[Music]
every time they bite metal their teeth
falls out but I thought it was I thought
it was uh I thought it was only if they
bite Bubble Boy
yeah whatever yeah I'm gonna go over
there I'm gonna get there that's carful
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah it's it's
that's Calvin okay all right yeah
everybody it's Calvin wait yeah where is
he wait yeah where you go Calvin Calvin
Calvin or Carl hook mum Flo Melvin how's
it going hey there you are
look oh look at the high five you know
Calvin used to do that all the time
before just because we've never seen
that animation before doesn't mean that
that's not Calvin cuz it is that's
definitely Calvin all right what did we
need for this plasteel ingot and power
cells yeah
all right all right let's just uh this
is me okay I've got that I just need the
lithium where did I put that stuff I I
put it in a lager herbai hush hush er
hush your beautiful faces everybody hush
your beautiful beautiful faces
you're all wonderful and beautiful but
it's fine alright anyway gotta make this
and then I gotta I gotta eventually make
an ample glass I don't need it right
right now so let's at least get this out
of the way for now just another power so
how did it cost to make a Power Cell ion
powder cell ion battery oh [ __ ] I gotta
make an iron battery oh well that's not
so bad I think I have all that I got the
ion cube I need gold and silver okay
silver nope gold and the ion cube which
is where the heck nope they are okay no
I need two of them that's right I need
two of them I got that gold another gold
another silver we're about I keep doing
that uh we're about good to go art one
of these do but there we go alright and
we need the silicon rubber which is
right here gotta keep doing that and
okay so we got that we're good to go
got everything we need who'd leader leo
Thank You Chandler eyes let's see there
were so many easier ways but it worked
are you talking about getting the
kyanite yeah probably but you know I
like the way I did it it was
death-defying you made me seem very
brave made me seem extremely brave watch
I just I just like I'm driving bubblegum
like back to the base and I just slam
right into Calvin just like straight up
thunk bump well there goes
Alvin how it's hit my own ass oh darn
Melvin now it's good to know about
Malvin help Melvin did what Melvin did
good be good to know all right
boink whoa that's a big boy that's a big
boy that's such a big boy look at that
big boy
look it down big boy gun on Island on on
an island wait okay wait all right are
you guys saying that this gun is on an
island all right okay Worsley island
guys where's your Island you know that
this game is called subnautica right
it's about being under the ocean you're
gonna see any islands here okay guys
yeah you did your best you did your best
but you're not gonna pull a fast one on
me I know exactly what's going on here
you guys you guys think you guys think I
don't know oh wow man you know you would
have had me but you just went a little
too deep there little too deep about an
island in this game okay yeah sure all
right all right
oh well all right where's Calvin can i
where's Calvin hang on where's Calvin
Calvin Calvin Calvin there you are come
in those clothes Calvin that was really
close Calvin Wow man you gotta be more
careful Calvin oh man that was a close
one
all right anyway oh boy all right hang
on hang on hang on I gotta pull the
shield module from this one because I'm
not gonna need it here anymore that's
for damn sure
um okay shield module I'm gonna get some
mmm okay so I got the shield module I
need the I know what I need
what hit me Calvin hit me dude Calvin
didn't run his ass into the side of the
ship like okay here's one of those dudes
let me see if this guy's gonna bite the
CMOS is that I always have the worst
luck with this I don't know what it is
these guys just do not want to bite me
and wait they want to bite me but then
they never lose a tooth look I'm looking
sorry
where's a tooth where's a tooth look I'm
looking turn no tooth or is it only when
they bite this metal is that what it is
I don't know okay bite that metal no
he's coming to bite me cuz that's what
it used to be right he used to be get
him to bite the the seamoth and then
they would I always have the worst luck
with this I have the worst luck with
this
not a tooth no let me try I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try something I'm gonna move
his metal I'm gonna move the metal like
over here oh that's not good
well I'm Audi oh oh
ie I pissed myself up hey
okay ah so we just picked that up no
tooth you picked that up no tooth okay
you have the worst luck with this Oh
skin uh right right the scanner room
yes exactly what did I just hit did I
hit Kappa did I hit Calvin what happened
right the scanner room that I built that
I never ever used right got it got it
got it got it got it got I gotta gotta
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta
gotta gotta got it got it got it got it
got it I got it
ah that's a lot of scans good job there
buddy okay stop that scan you're gonna
look for okay
you're gonna yeah all right sure oh oh
there's a winner right there what did
you look at wait where is it that is man
oh hang on that's not right that's
that's below the world that fell below
the world okay all right but but yeah
that that's also below the that's below
the world that's that's fault
I don't know about that thank you
wall is going Caleb's Alice use the
propulsion Canon on the scrap that works
almost every time what am I doing with
this scrap do I just throw it at him go
shoot him with it
that's not what I do I'm gonna assume
that's what I do that seems about right
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna shoot a
scrap Adam hey buddy come on over here
come on over here wait
Wow
not necessary come here whoa hang on
here take this take some of this take
this oh he took it okay I don't know oh
oh oh it works almost every time I'm out
of here I'm out of baby I'm out
whoo Thank You Caleb's Alice that is
worthy of getting a name on a locker if
ever there was one
Caleb Hollis Thank You Caleb Caleb Caleb
everybody give it up for Caleb okay so I
got with that now I can make some
enameled glass if I still that glass ami
which I don't of course I don't all
right
the most difficult thing that I thought
it was gonna be all right
oh I didn't even make another plasteel
that's right all right two of those
actually two of those an ingot oh I'm
out of ink it's but I'm not out of
titanium that's for sure okay make an
ingot let's make a plasteel more good oh
and an analyst plasteel and i think and
a computer chip I think a computer chip
is the only other thing that we need
yeah just a computer chip okay so that
just requires some table coral which is
nearby
i I depleted that deposit of table coral
over there so I gotta find another one
come on where's the goddamn table core
oh there we go all right
all right let's do whoa
hi are you staring longingly at big box
Barry oh you're the one that big oh okay
so you and big box Barry you got it on
could you get out of my face I just feel
like you're not in the right right you
know what
since I'm gonna leave soon you guys just
have a good time I guess you guys just
have a good time I guess I mean that's
all that I really can hope for at this
point so congratulations
any gold what is gold and copper wire
right
you have table core in big box Barry I'm
aware what I have in big bucks Barry but
I don't need it I got table coil right
in front of me right now yeah all right
dad later - did Lily do you all right so
I got that I have everything that I need
then right yeah yeah I do yes I do
yes I do I do have everything that I
need
all right okay all right then let's go
for this bad boy let's do this this it's
time it's time for this and thank you
Peter the homey Kyra Schumann's stormy
stories Maui v Dustin party roni for
Josh to a Kennedy Zorn kill kill Fang uh
Tiger King thank you all so much I think
this is it I think this is the wine man
if I'm not mistaken this is this is it
is it guys
oh wait I need to get up on the elevator
oh wait no the elevators at the top
because I jumped off last time I forgot
about that
good dude dude guys guys it's here
dude it's here it's here oh there's
another planet Oh guys whew hydraulic
systems Oh communications array Oh
auxiliary power unit oh oh oh wow can't
believe I built all this wow wow wow
activate life support prepare time
capsule who put up the primary CPU oh oh
oh couldn't save oh this is a good one
okay all right
boot up the CPU toot-toot and Neptune
you're a beautiful sounding prepare the
time capsule Oh image on a pan wait here
uh take all of my piss
[Laughter]
does it up ugly and here lies the
bargain player hey he came to this rock
with nothing but his wits and a full
bladder he leaves
the only thing that mattered to him so
cool that's so cool
alright yeah I see what you're saying as
he were saying yeah III know what I
should take a picture of you guys are
right you guys are absolutely right so
I'll be I'll be right back I'll be right
back
all right oh you all right over there
all right whatever
whoops bluesy
nice dive nice dive nice dive Oh lover's
quarrel over or did I miss the fireworks
all right hang on I got this where's
Calvin Calvin come here Calvin Calvin no
the knife that's not that's uh there's
nothing nice that I can Calvin come here
ever okay and there we go
that's probably good one let me get one
more I actually only get one more Hey
there we are there we are all right so I
got that I got that I got that turn off
the gun
turn off the good yeah okay all right
turn off the gun Hey oh wait sorry yeah
it's off all right the guns off guys the
gun is off all right sure all right so I
got everything I need I got everything I
need
I've got you can't you can't you can't I
don't think I can take Calvin with me I
don't think I could nothing again I
don't think you can everybody say
goodbye to Calvin everybody say goodbye
everybody say goodbye to Calvin Collins
unfortunately has to stay behind it's
very sad storage no well I wish I could
bring Calvin auxilary power your junk
nice
Communications right yeah yeah yeah
pressurizing hydraulics pressurizing I
growl systems all systems are go for
liftoff and let me I just got to adjust
the the picture here we go
uh which one I like this would whoa what
ball Huck uh-oh
ah that's a good one
aw that's so cute oh it's so cute I'm
gonna miss Calvin gonna miss Calvin I'm
gonna miss it
all right let's do this
let's go well quarantine enforcement
platform is still active
oh the quarantine enforcement platform
yeah why didn't you guys tell me to turn
off the quarantine enforcement platform
that was an important detail why did you
leave that out of that you didn't tell
me to turn off the guys I rely on you
for so many things you didn't tell me
about the quarantine enforcement
platform why didn't you do that
everybody knows the quarantine in
Florida meant platform is on that
mountain there God and that's not an
island that's a mountain these guys come
on I rely on you for one thing and you
let me down every time you let me down
why don't no one said turn off the
quarantine enforcement platform God guys
why don't you warn me about these things
fine okay I'll go turn off the
quarantine enforcement platform yeah
okay all right you can't you can't do it
it just doesn't work doesn't work
doesn't work you can't can't take wait
what Oh
Oh
[Music]
I'm bringing one of these just in case I
need it
wait maybe I need to make like artifact
I don't know I don't even know if I have
that recipe I don't actually Thank You
Me At su-85 have told me to do that Oh
cow that I barely met you and I
definitely didn't murder you and I know
you're probably better off here because
you get to live in an environment that's
friendlier to you I didn't have any
water on the rocket so you wouldn't have
been able they were so cute god damnit
Kelvin
all right now I'm gonna go turn off the
quarantine enforcement platform shoot
Calvin to space with the propulsion
cannon I don't think that's a good idea
something something tells me that that's
a it's quite a bad idea oh oh it's uh oh
it's so cute
my god that is cute my god that's cute
all right I'm okay I'm okay I'm gonna
stop being a little baby about it I'm
gonna stop being a little baby I'm gonna
turn off the quarantined enforcement
platform oh man miss Foxy Calvin shall
live on shadow 386 don't forget to
customize your rocket let's see you know
even if I could bring Calvin with me it
wouldn't be right you know like it
wouldn't be right cuz this is Calvin's
home I couldn't care for him as well
he's he's a big boy can could survive on
his own
Calvin what a good good oh I guess I
forgot that I I haven't been here since
it was like still in development oh yeah
yeah Wow I have not been it whoa do you
lead with the Hecht but that does this
portal lead wait a minute
have I forgotten something here oh it
probably leads to the C Emperor's temple
down way down below how do you turn this
thing off again I've completely
forgotten I'll take that thank you
is there even a way to turn it off here
or is it somewhere else
I cannot remember guys is this is this
here or is this in the Emperor area what
is that whoa what's that
where are you shaking I don't like that
Oh Oh
scans indicate this device contains
enough potential energy to destroy the
entire planet along with most of the
solar system fortunately it has
malfunctioned okay alrighty then
okey-dokey then ooh there's a pink
tablet over there I might need that yeah
it's there it's here yes here yes there
i none of those was an answer it's here
yeah I thought it was here
alright I just got to find it oh man
yeah it's crazy to think that the last
time that I was here was when it was uh
when all this was still in development
when it wasn't even ready yet none of
this was here and none of this was ready
that's crazy to think about yeah oh good
I did I did need one of these huh how
convenient that is thank you for that
all right
probably over here somewhere yeah that
looks important let me see if I can blow
that up hmm all right we'll see about
that
ooh I'll interact with you will hesitant
wink
ah
[Music]
don't like that oh god damn it I'm gonna
die before I'm able to get out of here
don't like that at all
that's no good that's a no bueno
a little bit lag here two bits all right
all right whoa what is over there I've I
never noticed that before I don't have
another tablet so I can't exactly go
through there ah that like the entrance
to it no no no now whatever I don't have
a tablet it's already too late I'm
probably already seen it
you're being piss you talked about piss
mmm delicious all right ha yeah yeah the
last thing I'm gonna do somebody
mentioned I just want to make sure I can
say goodbye to the sea upper and I don't
know if there is a way to say goodbye
but just kind of didn't die so I was
nice looks like the the children are
gone yeah I don't know if this is gonna
mean anything but I'm just gonna go down
there name the rocket Calvin I can name
the rocket that sounds awesome
ah thank you so much Rick regular deep
cut well thank you so much I'm gonna
actually do that yeah I would love to
name the rocket Calvin that's so nice I
didn't know I can name the rocket oh
wait you're still breathing
Oh No
I'm gonna give you a little focus on the
head no not that not that
godbye big amps you were cutie you're so
strong and you did such an amazing job
for your children you watched over them
so so beautifully I'm gonna miss you
I'm gonna miss you you did what it took
you sacrificed everything to make sure
that those kids got out there and you
trusted me and that means the world to
me
everybody say goodbye to them this is so
sad it's so sad I might cry I might
actually cry oh the babies are in five
different biomes and you can see them
off that's so good for them
Oh
that's so sweet
all right the time has come and this
whole platform is dark that's crazy
should I say goodbye to the Reaper
Leviathan - goodbye thanks for all the
fish an [ __ ] whoa that thing is
folding all right well that's the thing
all right so ya see a quarantine
enforcement platform there ain't no
disease here anymore we're all good to
go
there's just one last thing that I have
to do before I get out of here one last
thing I have to huh I gotta get
something from the babies got bigger the
babies grew up wait what where are they
wait where are they han wait let me look
up the sea Emperor children where are
they where are those sweet babies where
are those sweet baby babies where are
the sweet babies are those bamboos where
the babies come on
there we go the juveniles ah the crag
filled the dunes the grand reef for the
mountains northern blood kill oh I think
it said the mountains I'm actually near
the mountains right now it's hard to see
anything in the middle of the night but
there might be like something around
here
I'm not our descent sure yeah I'm not I
wasn't sure but I'm gonna look in the
mountains here because it said it says
Mountain crack fields doing mountains so
I'm gonna assume I'm gonna zoom I'm
gonna assume it's gonna be big enough
that I can see it number one and number
two I'm just gonna assume that if it's
here I'm gonna spot it now I don't know
how deep it'll be you guys keep your
eyes peeled we're looking from for
something that might be huge might not
be huge
who knows honestly because this is the
mountains I believe these this biome
here god I wish it wasn't night you know
that's one of the one of the big honkers
you think I make a do you think it makes
a noise I think it makes any sound yeah
I'm trying to find it I'm trying to find
an emperor right now just don't know
where there would be I'm sure this is
the mountain zone wow there's a lot of
you guys oh not you
god dammit you you made me think [ __ ]
oh I where am i right now who did I hear
a reaper Ruth that's not good okay I'm
not sure yeah wait a second I'm not
gonna lose ya well god damn it go away
God just get day already
I need daylight gotta be near here
markets right there oh really it's right
there where where do you where do you
say yelling at me doesn't make me find
it any sooner steam you up
hey hey [ __ ] [ __ ] off stupid douche
they stay near the surface okay that's
good to know
[Music]
go away I'm having a moment here you
look so good all right all right all
right it looks so good oh you grew up so
big I don't know if I can interact with
you you seem to be going a little too
fast for me hello you remember me I'm
like your papa I'm here papa all right
never mind then oh good good all right
oh gosh gosh gosh gosh thank you weirdly
Meg I just want to say thank you for
being awesome I can turn to you when I'm
at my lowest thank you for reminding me
how to laugh for showing me that there's
good in the world when I feel like
everything is hopeless well thank you so
much for being here with me thank you so
much for just enjoying all this thank
you everybody for enjoying all this
thank you everybody so much for enjoying
this series like I know we're coming to
a close here and I want to figure out
how to customize a rocket and I'm gonna
get one last thing from my base to put
in the rocket but yeah this is it's
really something special like this
really is this whole thing was something
special like this whole adventure
like conquering not conquering I'm still
terrified of the ocean but acknowledging
my fear of the ocean you get forcing
myself to dive deep down and just kind
of like explore this horrifying world
with with this real sense of danger and
wonder like this real sense of it
and going through the journey of the
fact that I've been playing this game
for about two years now like that's
that's something incredible and it's
something really really wonderful and
and I I know you guys are saying like
there's probably a way to take Calvin
with me but you have to understand that
wouldn't be the right move it wouldn't
be the right move it wouldn't be right
to take Calvin with me on to this
adventure because in the rocket like
Calvin can't survive there I don't have
an aquarium for Calvin Calvin here now
that the ocean is safe and he can live
in the ocean here it's not safe safe but
it's safe enough that he can survive
here like this is where Calvin should be
Calvin shouldn't be with me sometimes
it's important to let go even if you
want like it's for what's best for
Calvin and not for me and what's
definitely not best for Calvin is a
propulsion gun right to the face but
that's another story entirely and that
didn't actually happen but you know it's
just really fun like to go through all
this and to to play this game and like
see everything that's here and to see
like all the wonderful things that came
out of it and to know that like this
this brought so much joy and the reason
I wanted to finish this off in a live
stream is because I wanted to be here
with you guys to experience it all at
the same time and and even if someone's
watching this from the future which I
know people go through much my series
all the time
boink got it people go through my series
all the time like over and over again
and you know but I wanted to experience
this with you guys like directly because
something important and I wanted to
finish it off right and find these last
few things without being rushed like in
any way and you know what Karen I'm
gonna miss you the most Karen because
apparently Neptune has a different book
Karen I love you Karen Karen I love you
but you made that happen one last
goodbye from Karen you sack you sack of
[ __ ] you sack of [ __ ] oh my god oh yeah
greatest can wait why don't it scan this
thing oh whoops
scan that into oblivion apparently oh
geez oh man
oh oh there we go yeah I got stuff to do
but yeah
besides all that silliness yeah goodbye
Karen Karen with a K Calvin with the C
this is good you know it's good one last
surprise before I get out of here now
how do I customize you how do I
customize this bad boy is it on the
panel to build it
Geoffrey Billy Samwise and Marshall
you're good too
you did a good job ah here we go I'm
gonna nave him
yeah all right we're gonna put this bad
boy we're gonna make this bad boy the
best shade of pink oh that is very penis
[Laughter]
it's real nice that's real nice that has
a real nice oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
that's a beaut that's a beaut right
there that is a beaut right there oh
she's a beaut she's a beaut
oh she's a beauty she's a big honking
beauty she's a great big throbbing
beauty look at her look at her
oh hell yeah look at look at her looking
all her majesty oh it really just smacks
you right in the face it just kind of
pops out it yeah ooh
well she's a beauty oh she's a beauty
all right hmm
yeah get a look at her get a look at her
huh ah that's some good stuff that's
some good
I love the bulbous tip I think that's my
favorite part of it
the yellow door this is Oh looks like a
dildo what are you talking about I don't
know a weirdo what are you what are you
even saying all right this is the good
stuff and where can I put my poster hang
on I got to put my poster somewhere put
my poster nope
well actually that is it when you save
we're gonna put my poster we're gonna
put my poster where my poster go down
where my poster going oh my god I've
already said goodbye to Calvin I've
already said goodbye to Calvin Oh what
what I can't put my poster up oh you
sexy I'll carry my poster with me I got
my poster in my art I got my poster
right here I have the capitalist right
here but I can't put it up here but this
is it
this is the one I'm really excited about
this no time to waste all right let's do
this
yeah oh my god this is it this is it
this is it Oh Calvin let's do this
oh hi you should move probably
- one
time capsule jettison
[Music]
ah
motion approaching orbital debris debris
field clear performing gravity turn
maneuver oh wait look at that island
wait what is that island there's another
one Oh No is that the Aurora no there's
confirmed destination coordinate there's
more islands on this barest interstellar
phase gate
engaging ion Bustos and three two one
whoa
that was big wait what was that whoa
[ __ ]
oh the god damn ah where are they going
Wow holy [ __ ] what is their way without
the ocean a beginning without an end
they are different but they go together
now you go among the stars in I fall
among the sighs we are different but we
go together
[Music]
but yeah what was that I saw there was a
huge huge land mass there there was a
huge one that was like I think that's
what the arctic area because I heard
that they wanted to do Arctic stuff on
this game and they do they're gonna do
it let me turn that music down oh it's
the fire fire dubstep let's turn that
way down way down with it oh man oh man
Mamba Jamba man ah that is so cool that
is so cool oh that's so cool
god dammit it's so so cool man it's
really something special like to see it
come all this way I you know when it
first starts out you never think that
it's actually gonna come that far I
didn't but this is why I wanted to wait
until the final version of the game came
out before I tried it like to actually
finish the game it was fun to be able to
like do this oh look at all the
production babies I look at you like it
was fun to play it as the updates came
out but I knew there was gonna be
something really special in the game
finally came in jacksepticeye DPI pariah
neck we're done is Anthony awesome
grunts up-tempo music later Dan Ryan oh
that's so nice this is so nice Oh
oh that's so nice
Cyclops is a registered trademark Oh a
trillion Wow [ __ ] oh boy well that sucks
I think I might have been better off in
the ocean anyway that's subnautica thank
you everybody so much for joining me on
this wonderful journey this has been
such a cool adventure it's been so fun
and this may not be the end of
subnautica there may be more stuff I
believe they want to do some extra stuff
with it this is such a cool cool concept
and they've put so much work into it
everybody thank you everybody so much
for watching and giving all the love in
the world to all the developers of this
game making this something special and I
know that there's gonna be more to come
there will be more to come and I will
play it when it gets there but for me to
you thank you guys so much for being
with me on this journey thank you for
joining me on this livestream if you're
watching this in the future thank you
for watching through the entirety of the
series and thanks again let me know what
you think down in the comments let me
know you're thinking super chat let me
know anything in the future there's
gonna be a lot of cool stuff to come I
can't wait to see what happens next so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye bye guys
bye bye bye bye guys bye
by